Gary Giddins writer critic
well I think all of us begin as writers
I wanted to be a writer from the time I
was 8 long before I ever heard of jazz
the question is once you have that
obsession what is your subject going to
be and you often don't know for some
time it might become fiction it might be
nonfiction and if it's nonfiction it
could go in any number of directions I
didn't realize what my subject was for
quite some time I thought I was I know I
wanted to write criticism because I
loved reading criticism and I just had a
response to that and I knew I had an
ability for it but I studied English
literature and expect it to be a
literary critic jazz was something that
I loved it was an obsession of mine but
I wasn't a musician or a musicologist I
didn't think I really had the right to
write about jazz but then after I got a
school out of school my first job
actually was as a film critic for The
Hollywood Reporter and and I felt that
the jazz criticism was terribly lacking
a lot of the things I wanted to say and
the musicians I admired weren't being
written about or I felt I had something
to say that nobody else was saying and
people would say to me editor's you know
you know a lot about jazz would you do a
jazz piece for me and finally I just bit
the bullet and and left to a film
writing for gosh about 50 more than 15
years and then really committed myself
entirely to jazz crib
who sort of made the veil drop from my
eyes was Dwight MacDonald MacDonald was
a film critic for Esquire in the early
60s and he was very funny and polished
and I really liked his voice and then
shortly after that I discovered Edmund
Wilson particularly the two I remember
buying Axl's castle and and and having a
hard time with it because I hadn't read
most of the writers in it but then I got
the shores of light which is his
collection of essays from the 20s and
classics and commercials and Wilson
really sort of set me on my path there
were a number of other critics at the
same time that I was reading James ag's
film reviews in jazz the two critics I
loved the most will Martin Williams and
Dan Morgenstern I became completely
obsessed with a turn-of-the-century
critic who wasn't read anymore I don't
know why named James Gibbon Honaker who
published some two dozen volumes and a
notorious novel about an orgy at the
Opera that called painted veils which is
once the bestseller but I don't even
think that's in print anymore
Max Baer bombs theater criticism I love
Shaw's music criticism well you know I
became completely obsessed with reading
criticism Johnson was that was a big
thing in my life when I first started to
read lives at the poet's and Matthew
Arnold Elliott's criticism I ended up
doing my senior thesis on Edmund Wilson
TS Eliot and Hemingway as critics so I
got that I think that path was pretty
much clear for me at that point
that's an interest
question I think that I should begin by
just briefly exploring the issue of who
won rights for and and I've always
thought it for me it's there's no
question about it that you're writing
for some version of yourself you're
writing the kinds of things that you
like to read or want it to read at a
certain point so primarily for most of
my career I've written the kind of
criticism that fascinates me the things
I discover the things that get me going
that I'm excited about at the same time
you want to share that enthusiasm but
this new book jazz was a very deliberate
attempt to put the literary issues aside
and even some of the more constant
enthusiasms that really try to share
what I've learned in 45 years about the
way jazz works how to listen to it it's
always sort of bugged me that people are
intimidated by it they're intimidated by
improvisation they say I like it but I
don't really understand it as though
there was something mystical and and
complicated and I found from teaching
years ago and Scott DeVoe my my
co-author on this book who is a
dedicated professor at the University of
Virginia for a quarter of a century you
find out that at least I found that that
when I explained what a blues form is
twelve bar blues a thirty-two bar pop
song it just clicks in people's heads
and suddenly they began to hear popular
music in a whole different way there's a
wonderful story that Martin Williams
used to tell he was lecturing it I think
he was lecturing at NYU as a guest
lecturer and he started explaining the
12-bar blues in the thirty two bar pop
song and the fact that 90% of all the
pop songs that were written in America
thirty-two bar is a ABA and there was a
guy in the in the in the audience who
was a basically a cocktail pianist he
earned his living playing at Holiday
Inns and he knew thousands of songs and
as Martin is talking about the a ABA
form he suddenly slaps his forehead and
says that's right
so I mean even even this guy who knows
the wall hadn't really figured it
thought of that thought of it that way
but when you hear it when you understand
the way courts work in the end the way
harmonies build and then resolve and
eight-bar increments or twelve bars
suddenly improvisation doesn't seem so
complicated anymore and for me the trick
is to learn how to listen the way the
musicians are listening which is not
that difficult
I'm not a musicologist so this book was
really written for people who have no
more musical logical ability than I do
the the the challenge in analyzing the
78 tracks that we chose was in doing it
in a language that was not music
illogical
no writing style is something that is a
consequence of who you are I think that
I had a certain ability a certain
propensity for a style that I recognized
in my early work but that doesn't mean I
didn't have to learn certain basics and
the longer you write the better you get
it's it's a you know the the rhythms
come from you if the rhythm seemed to
echo the music then that's that's
delightful if if people see that but
it's certainly not something that's
intentional and on my part I'm trying to
be as clear and precise as I can be and
at the same time I'm trying to be
eloquent and witty and entertaining I
mean writing should be a pleasure one of
the things I always underscore when I
teach criticism is that young critics or
would-be critics frequently have this
illusion that if they write about music
there's somehow part of music or if they
write about movies they're part of
movies or if they're write about theater
they're part of theater or write about
literature that writing is a part of
literature I mean with that's what we
belong to this species of literature if
you add all the music reviews together
that have ever been written they don't
create two notes of music so the the
question of jazz or film or whatever the
subject is it's just a matter of finding
the subject that allows you to express
yourself as a writer I mean critics just
as novelists write about the world
through the fabrications of fictive
fictional imagination we write about the
world as we experience it through the
Arts and for me jazz as a way to deal
with you know the development of the
20th century on so many different levels
especially race the high art forces low
art controversy that never ends and then
the whole way into an art that's fairly
recent develops how it starts in a
community as a kind
folk music just functionally supporting
the the dance traditions of us of one
little place and then it spreads and
everyplace it spreads it's changed by
whatever community it enters when it
goes to new york it's completely changed
when it goes to Chicago it's completely
changed and then at some point it
becomes worldwide and even popular music
and then suddenly it becomes more
self-conscious about itself as an art
and leaves the popular stage and then it
becomes a thing that academics studies
so this whole thing you know you can
write about it in terms of the stage or
literature but you're then you're
writing really about something that
happen long before you were born but
with jazz or cinema it's really these
are arts that are about a hundred years
old so we're writing about something
pretty much as it's happening and that's
very exciting
well anything everything that's of any
value merits academic study and I
suppose even some things aren't of any
value and there's all kinds of popular
culture courses that go into areas that
I don't really see the point of but the
the sad truth is that in the 1930s or
1940s people but me when I was growing
up in the 60s I listened to jazz because
I loved it I didn't need anybody
I could teach myself about it by you
know reading books and reviews but
mostly through listening I hate the idea
of turning it in of jazz into a homework
assignments I mean I would never you
know have a quiz say who's the
clarinetist on the hot five I don't care
if you like the clarinet is you'll know
who it is I don't you know that
but appreciation is another thing the
music appreciation a way how to how to
enjoy it
I mean I'm I am astounded at my age with
a 20 year old daughter to discover that
kids of her generation don't want to
watch black and white movies I
understand that they gave up on silent
films but black and white and so now
movies have to be taught in academia
because people don't know how to watch
them they don't know how to appreciate
them so it's inevitable that that's
where that's where it's gonna happen but
if the class turns it into something dry
and academic and a question of
memorization and I say the hell with it
if it doesn't give you pleasure go
someplace else
jazz is for joy it's for euphoria it's
for it's for emotion and and and anguish
and excitement and all of the joys that
great art can produce and if it loses
that then then it's lost everything
well I am I why really my my answer to
that hasn't changed and most of the
years I've been doing this I think first
of all if if your critic I'm a critic
that means you're a writer so yes you
have to make yourself an authority on
whatever subject it's gonna be music
movies literature whatever it's gonna be
but what you really want to do is learn
your trade by reading other writers I
think you have to read voraciously
especially people who have done what
you've done to see what how it's been
done in the past what works what doesn't
work when I teach criticism I'm not a
great admirer of Pauline Kael forgive me
I know a lot of people are but I used to
use Pauline Kael as an example in my
class of everything you what not to do
from the imperial lead to the arrogance
to the predictability of liking anything
by a certain artist or hating anything
by another certain artist but on the
other hand yes you should read her for
yourself
obviously by reading different critics
you find that who speaks to you and what
kind of voice you want to have so I
think that that's the first thing and
then in terms of succeeding because of
who you are and what your voice is and
you have to have passion if you don't
have a passion for it
why would you bother this is not a way
to make a living in any conventional
sense so you really need to have the
passion to and the belief arrogant
though it may be to believe that you're
saying something that nobody else is
saying
the early years of my work I have to say
I often felt guilty because I was having
such a good time I couldn't believe I
was allowed to make a living
first of all listening to this music
that I loved and writing about it and
there is something bizarre about
spending your days exploring the
obsessions of your adolescence and but
as you as you get older you want to get
different you want to do different
things you first use sort of delivering
yourself of everything you know and a
part of your early writing and I noticed
this in the young critics all the time
and I was certainly guilty of this is
that there's a bit of showing off
because you've just entered the stage
and you want to prove that you have
something so so you're sometimes making
statements that are louder than they
need to be this is too many masterpieces
and this is beneath contempt and you're
not really dealing with art in the right
proportion for me one way it changed was
that I was primarily concerned with live
performance for many years I loved
writing about recordings but I was out
there on average four nights a week for
the first I would say 15 years I was at
the voice and most of the pieces I did
were about what I heard live and I had
invented this job for myself at the
voice it didn't really exist in any
other publication which I never wanted
to be a daily critic who goes out every
night and writes 300 word reviews I
wanted to write essays and and that gave
me the luxury of being able to go out
and if it was lousy I could just say
well the hell with that I'll go to hear
something else or I'll go tomorrow night
I was writing for a weekly and I only
wanted to write and write things that
interested me as a writer as well as a
listener but then my daughter was born
in the late 80s and suddenly I started
resenting being out I wanted to be home
I wanted to be able to put her to sleep
I you know you don't get those chances
again and so I was out even realizing at
first I started going out less and I
started doing more and more columns
about recordings and in the course of
that I began my aesthetic change a lot I
think because first of all I was
exploring a lot of recordings that I
thought I knew
but as you get older they change as you
change and you begin to hear different
things and so that was one you know and
III I still wrote live about important
concerts and certainly festivals but at
the same time something else change with
me and that's this The Village Voice
once I got my column after I'd been
there for a year I had a column for 30
years I wrote it every other week 1,800
words for the most part
occasionally sitting down to 16
something like that
it was my page nobody ever told me what
how to fill it after a while you begin
to realize that spending eighteen
hundred words telling people not to buy
a recording that they never heard of in
the first place is stupid it's a waste
of your time it doesn't tell the reader
anything so I became much more of an
enthusiast I became much more of a
critic who wants to tell you you got to
hear this that's what I kept looking for
now I I listen to things blind I have an
assistant and she puts I have a you know
one of those CD players with five you
can put five dissin and she puts the
disks in and keeps the boxes in the
other room and I go through them and you
know with the remote if I see something
I like then I look usually I recognize
it but frequently I don't
and that way frequently is surprised
people let you think I don't want to
bother with will sometimes grab you and
other times well it can go either way
I worry far more about negative reviews
than positive ones when I if I'm
reviewing a record man I play that
record death which is ironic in a way
because if I review a concert I feel
very confident of myself
certainly at this point and have for
most of my career you're only hearing it
once and then you go to your typewriter
and you write the review but with a
record I'd never do that I have to play
the record over and over again and if I
don't like it I have to really kind of
come to grips with what is it that I
don't like and articulate it when I
teach criticism the first thing I say
and this sometimes pisses off younger I
mean you know students is that opinions
are the least part of criticism we've
all had the experience of going with a
friend to a movie or a concert and you
leave the theater and one of you loved
it and one of you hated it and that
doesn't mean that one of you is an idiot
that's the way things work now the
question is not who's right because
there is no right the question is how
you articulate it that's what criticism
comes into play there are reviews that
are clearly wrong dr. Johnson's famous
life of savage he's clearly wrong about
the value of savage but it's one of the
great works in English literature you
can learn more about the artistic
expression and what the poet does and
how to write about art from that then
any number of guys who are terrible
writers who have no original ideas but
who say yes Hamlet is a wonderful play
it's a meaningless statement so it's
it's all about it's it's all about first
of all being candid and honest letting
nothing else interfere with your
perception of the work and then finding
a means of articulation that somehow
makes the work come alive and if you
dislike it gives your argument some
validity I couldn't write that piece
today I actually have become much more
fond of ending really excited about
Keith's playing over the over years but
that's that's that's why criticism
ultimately at some degree is about the
writer
and not the subject you know it's very
easy if everybody else says he's a
genius too to echo that but then you're
not functioning as a critic or as a
writer in any meaningful way you've got
to take the risk of being wrong but my
feeling of course is that if you're
genuinely candid and expressive then
you're never wrong even when you are
wrong
the only sociological purpose I can
remember that I had to deal with and
sort of get past was race you know I
grew up with this idea that I mean it
was a fact it wasn't just an idea that
white musicians were given all kinds of
help that would denied black musicians
this is an african-american music most
of the great figures have been black and
yet in the 30s it was the white bands
that got all the great hotel gigs and
all the great radio hookups it was free
clean even in the 50s and 60s when I was
coming up to the white bands frequently
got the most attention I remember
everybody saying that Stan Getz was
punished for years because of something
that a critic wrote about him in Life
magazine Albert Goldman said that he was
the greatest saxophone player in the
world this was at a time in Coleman
Hawkins is alive and Sonny Rollins you
know and it was so offensive really what
if it's offensive to say that about
anybody cuz it was ridiculous but to
always it seems like it was always the
white guy and so a lot of people started
to put down Stan Getz and I remember
having lunch one day I was writing a
line a note for a wonderful saxophone
player a black musician when we were
having lunch and he made some kind of
disparaging remark about Stan Getz and I
had done this myself and I said but you
know isn't Stan a great player and he
looked at me and he said of course these
are great flier so you know you have to
sort of get by that you know guess who's
one of the supreme figures in my
judgment but but there was so much of
that and you and I really had to deal
with it and in the 70s I used to talk
about this with other critics white and
black that we'd say like if you're
standing on 20th Street and a new white
band is coming to town on 15th and a new
black band is coming into town on 25th
it's five blocks that way or this way
we'd all go to see the black band just
the assumption from history is that
something more is going to be happening
there so I think at some point you just
finally have to really try to become
colorblind and say this guy is saying
something and this is and this guy is it
and it isn't a question of race and it
isn't the quiet
question of gender that was a big issue
that we started to deal with because
while most of my favorite singers have
always been women there haven't been a
lot of really notable women
instrumentalists there you know Mary Lou
Williams the great genius she's always
the token female in every discussion of
instrumentalists and orchestrators and
composers but there have been so many
really gifted women players in the last
several years so so that's been
something that you have to deal with but
on the other hand you don't want to say
well she's really good just because
she's a woman or because she's cute
there was a lot of that too I remember
there was a notorious piece in an essay
in which this guy was going on and on
about this woman musician and he just
described her legs once too many times
to make an incredible piece
well first of all the work is never tied
to the judgment moby-dick widely
criticized if Yuri go back and read the
reviews that Melville got in the early
1950s these are not stupid people for
the most part they are actually put off
by what they consider to be this young
man's pretentiousness endearing to write
a Shakespearean novel we don't have that
same problem but it did take what 70
years from Moby Dick to find it's as a
professor at Columbia named Raymond
Weaver who started writing about it in
the early 20s right right around the
time they discovered the manuscript of
Billy Budd it's only since then that
Moby Dick has become this you know
mammoths work in our literature you know
and everybody knows that Vincent van
Gogh couldn't sell a painting and that
Thelonious among for many years was
considered a charlatan and Cecil Taylor
was considered a charlatan and all of
that kind of nonsense
very little criticism is has proven to
be enduring so it has to really be
essential I mean Aristotle yes some of
his criticism is enduring Johnson is
read by English majors like me I mean
try to find an inexpensive copy of lives
of the poet is not easy it's naughty you
know for a long time you couldn't find a
decent edition of Boswell's life of
Johnson Matthew Arnold's criticism isn't
read anymore Eliot's is not widely read
anymore there are very few you know
Wilson I think because so many of us
grew up with him and find him to be an
extremely important American writer but
look how many years it took for the
library of America to put out two
volumes of Edmund Wilson who founded the
library of America was his idea
and this was a great source of
embarrassment to the editors at the
library of America but you know
criticism didn't sell they put out two
volumes of Henry James criticism
brilliant stuff they put out Edgar Allen
Poe's criticism criticism is a hard sale
most people aren't interested in reading
it so I think it's mostly critics that
read classic criticism but to my sorrow
and I've had this conversation a zillion
times most even if my colleagues don't
read classic criticism and my feeling is
that if you don't do that then you're
not really practicing your craft that's
how you learn how to do it by those you
don't learn how to write about jazz just
from listening to jazz you learn how to
write by learn by reading the great
writers and that in how they worked the
great music critics now one of the
essential books that I always recommend
to anybody who wants to write about or
even think about music is a slim slim
skis what is it called the dictionary
musical invective and it's a collection
of quotes by critics over the last 250
years that are just so totally off base
that they're hilarious you know no one
will ever listen to Beethoven's third
Symphony
it's 40 minutes long and who will ever
listen to a 40 minutes so for me
Beethoven's response was to write a 90
minute symphony but when you read those
reviews in the context of their period
these are not stupid people they're
simply reflecting the tastes and the
limitations of that period but
solinsky's is a book you should have on
your bookshelf just to keep you humble
humility is a very important trait in a
critic
I wish I had a dollar for every time
someone has asked me that question and I
never have an answer I mean I would say
that Louis Armstrong is the be-all and
the end-all and you should certainly
listen to something by Armstrong in 1928
recordings were the you know one of the
great recordings from the 1950s of
modern jazz Ellington certainly there
should be an album by Ellington probably
a collection from the early 40s or maybe
a late work like it's funny the other
night I was listening just by
coincidence I was listening to
Stravinsky's petrushka and it reminded
me of a piece the bird of Delhi from one
movement of it from Ellington Safari
suite and I played Ellington Safari
suite a piece I've always loved and it's
greater than I and I always thought it
was great but it's greater it's even
greater than I thought I really feel
like now I want to write about it in a
completely different way so if you start
there you'll you'll you'll know who
Ellington is it doesn't have to be with
mood indigo or some you know agreed-upon
received wisdom masterpiece
everybody loves Miles Davis's kind of
blue so be different choose something
else like milestones or my funny
Valentine or you know porgy and bess I
mean these are all such magnificent
recordings monk I think solo monk nobody
can resist so a monk when I was in
school and the one thing that my
rock-and-roll friends who really didn't
have any interest in jazz they all ended
up buying monk you just can't resist
solo monk nobody can it's just too happy
and swinging and surprising and
whimsical and witty and brilliant and it
just makes you think about everything in
a different way that's that's more than
five already I suppose but I you know
one of the things we say in this book is
my job is to be a jazz a story and a
critic so I got to listen to everything
but you don't
you may love the swing error you may get
really turned on by Ellington and Basie
at Jimmie Lunceford and Benny Goodman
and Artie Shaw and Andy Kirk and all
these fantastic swing bands it doesn't
mean you're necessarily gonna love the
avant-garde you may I I think one of the
great periods is 1945 to 1949 when bebop
was really pure you know I'm not aware
of a bad record that was made in those
four years by anybody but you know you
make it completely obsessed with that
and they find you know traditional jazz
or swing dull and then at some point in
your life you may go back to it and say
hey now I get that the point is to go
with what really turns you on people
should not feel intimidated by received
wisdom you have to discover it yourself
if I tell you that I'm strong is great
it's meaningless
you have to hear it every once in a
while I I meet somebody who's just had
the Armstrong experience and it's always
the same and it I love it because at one
point you think well he's entertaining
or is this or that
but then suddenly they get it the way
they get box b-minor mass which for me
was the bench stone benchmark as a kid
and suddenly they know they know that
this guy really was God that there's
nothing you know Bing Crosby said that
Armstrong is the beginning and the end
of music in America and he wasn't far
wrong
Ken Burns when he was making his jazz
documentary I was very cynical about it
you know he was going around saying he
didn't know anything about jazz but that
in a few years he would and all of this
and I'm thinking it's not that easy and
then I was talking to him and he had
just been converted by Armstrong and you
can't disguise that it is he had a glow
on about it and the words he was using
and I thought brother you know he's in
the 10th fine
well nobody knows where jazz is going
because nobody has ever known jazz is
going I mean you couldn't possibly
predict a swing error from the 20s or
Bebop from the swing error or or
avant-garde from bebop or a fusion and
on and on and on so we don't really know
where it's going but I would say this I
don't think we're going to be seeing
those kinds of distinct and discrete
movements like swing bobbing fusion I
think now it's a question of individuals
now yeah one thing is important to
remember is that in the early years of
jazz a lot of major amuse issues like
Fletcher Henderson and Don Redman had
you know college education Xand and
degrees and all of that but a lot of the
great figures like Louis Armstrong of
Duke Ellington Charlie Parker did not I
mean officer didn't even go to high
school of the hundreds if not thousands
of major figures learned on the
bandstand that was their apprenticeship
today the apprenticeship of musicians in
the college orchestra I mean he's not
gonna meet a musician who hasn't you
know got at least a BA and probably an
MA and hasn't been to a music school and
hasn't had giant steps as a homework
assignment so it's very different so
they so because they have this
historical perspective they aren't
necessarily just coming out of whatever
their generation is into and also
because they're growing up and they
don't have the same prejudices against
pop music that certain generations had
they can use that so you know today's
musicians who maybe grow up with hip hop
may use hip hop beats in a way that if
you're not looking for them you won't
even hear it
but it's there it's informing the way
they think of rhythm and they may use
things that they picked up from
Ellington or Dizzy Gillespie that isn't
particularly obvious it's not a homage
it's not a matter of playing Kannamma or
a sophisticated lady it's just releasing
Zords some idea that they picked up so
all of this becomes part of the the brew
and what we're really looking for in the
future of jazz is the individual who is
saying something that expresses him or
herself that's what I look for I look
for some spa
of originality or individuality that
sets this musician apart from the pack
there were the general level of
musicianship in jazz is probably higher
now than it's ever been I can't get very
excited about a musician who can do our
tatum because I've got the are Tatum
records I want to hear him take that and
do something that hasn't been done and
there's enough of that going around
that keeps the music very exciting
there's so many great young players
coming out I think we're doing some kind
of Renaissance especially in the rhythm
section I mean where the musicians on
drums and bass and and guitar really
trying to figure out different ways to
bring a rhythm section together so I you
know the crossover is a constant thing
one of the things we do in the book
which i think is fairly novel I don't
think anyone's done it before but we
have two chapters on fusion instead of
one everybody when they talk about
fusion they usually are talking about
the jazz rock thing that happened in the
late 60s and 70s when Miles Davis
recorded bitches brew and you know
chicory ax and and John McLaughlin and
all these guys came along and had fusion
bands using elements of rock but we make
an argument that fusion has always been
part of jazz and that you can actually
create a sort of fusion history of jazz
if you go back even into the 30s where
did Louie Jordan the father rhythm blues
come out of the Chick Webb Orchestra you
know where did the salsa movement come
out of machito and Mario Bowser who
played with and Dizzy Gillespie who
played with all the big bands there's
always been you know Jelly Roll Morton
said you can't make jazz without using
certain elements of Latin music so
there's always been this let me say it
this way I'll quote Dexter Gordon's
famous line he said jazz is an octopus
it will take whatever it can use and it
will work with it so III think that
distinctions aren't as clear as we like
to think Jason Moran who is the subject
of the last chapter in our book because
we decided to use instead of trying to
cover the whole scene we try it we
decided to use a representative jazz
musician you know at the age of 30 when
she was at that time we were ready and
the two tracks we analyzed by him
one is his version of a 1930 James P
Johnson stride piece called you've got
to be modernistic which he takes
completely into the realm of of
thoroughly modern semi upon gorgeous and
the other is Afrika Bambaataa z-- planet
rock which he does the same now anybody
knows the James P number will recognize
anybody knows the Bambaataa number will
recognize it but they will also see that
he's done something completely different
and it's not a question of doing
something clever or cute this is what he
grew up with it's his right to use it
we're gonna see a lot more of that